sorry Mr Novak tell me about the March
later on okay well this will be March
part of our wider series of activities
that are being held today too support
our campaign to protect the right to to
strike but also to stand up for our
public services and support those
hundreds of thousands of public sector
workers who are taking strike action
today around pay and have been taken
strike action over the last few few
weeks and months so this is part of our
whole series of activity up and down the
country and we hope that the governments
will take it seriously and listen to the
voices of working people why do you
think they will well I I would hope that
any employer would have the good grace
in the sense to listen to the staff when
the staff tell them that there's a
problem and there clearly is a problem
it doesn't matter whether it's teachers
civil servants physiotherapists
paramedics lots of workers saying we
can't afford another year of a real
terms pay cut now as I say okay I would
expect any employer to say well listen
let's listen to your concerns let's
respond to those concerns and let's try
and deliver a fair pay rise and up until
now unfortunately the government hasn't
done that but I'm an optimist and I'm a
negotiator and I hope that the
government will listen and we'll come to
the table um education secretary sat
there a moment ago she said do what you
want there's no more money well you know
government is all about political
choices and I'm afraid this government
has made the wrong choices now Jimmy
Keegan has right to a certain extent
it's rissy shunnak and Jeremy Hunt that
needs to make the money available to
fund a decent pay rise and so far the
Prime Minister and his Chancellor have
been missing in action I think last time
I was on your program uh two or three
weeks ago I said that we wanted to sit
down with the chancellor and the PM to
talk about what could be done in terms
of fair pay settlement new money on the
table we haven't had a response well I'm
not interested in beer and sandwiches or
indeed Italian sympathy what I'm
interested in doing is resolving these
disputes but resolving them in a way
that puts money in the pockets of all
those public sector workers who say they
can't afford another real Thames uh pay
cut and that you know we've talked in
the past about the Staffing crisis in
our NHS 300 000 vacancies into Care
Homes and in the NHS we've got a
staffing crisis in our classrooms as
well I mean a third of teachers around a
quarter of a million of them have left
the profession within 10 years of
qualifying that's a problem for for our
school and it's a problem for the
education of our kids so the government
has to do something that's not just
respond to those issues well it's it's
partly about money it's partly about
things like workload uh but you know
what is being addressed by the education
secretary well I I don't think the
reality is you can't resolve issues
around workload Recruitment and
Retention and not talk about pay at the
same time and that's where I think the
governments are playing a little bit
fast and loose with the British public
to say somehow these things aren't
connected they're absolutely connected
and really the government needs to sit
down as I say the Prime Minister and the
chancellor come to the table find some
new money
um yeah well they say there isn't any
more money the nurses want more money
the ambulance workers want more money
the train drivers want more money these
civil servants want more money border
control wants more money in what order
should people be getting money well it's
important to sort of differentiate so
for example the train drivers are
working for private companies those
companies have handed out hundreds of
millions of pounds in dividends to their
shareholders I think they could afford a
pay rise for their train drivers well
actually it's not about this group of
workers there's more deserving than the
other what we need is to see pay rise
and across the public and indeed the
private sector now what could the
government do about this the TUC will
put in its budget submission today we'll
be at the treasury today to put in our
budget submission and we'll be saying
that the government could for example
choose the taxi offshore at the oil and
gas giants more heavily they could use
to equalize capital gains tax with
income tax tax wealth in the same way
they tax workers that alone would
generate another 15 or 16 billion pounds
so government is all about choices
unfortunately this is government has
made the wrong choices well they are
going to wear you down basically and
it's going to get to April and then
they're going to say that was last year
third year money we're talking about
next year now well I hope that's not the
attitude to be honest with you okay the
the wearing down not just unions they're
wearing down the British public I mean I
think and I've been on the picket lines
with our physiotherapists with our
paramedics uh when the public are going
past beeping the horns talking to those
workers showing their support I think
they're very clear whose side the
British public are on and I hope the
government listens to that you know in
the problem not necessarily the case
promise he's been doing this long enough
to know what's going on and there will
be some support for our NHS but the
other unions that the government is
going to wait until the public turns
against them well I I think I think
they'll be waiting a long time to be
honest with okay I mean it's clear we
did a poll uh just last week that a
majority of parent support teachers take
in a strike action but at the end of the
day these are I mean these are our
friends our neighbors members of our
local community everybody knows a
teacher somebody works in the NHS
somebody who works on the railways and I
think trying to the government trying to
divide the British public away from
striking workers I think we're won't
succeed because those striking workers
are part of the local community they've
got those you know the face of those
public services and I want the
government to treat them with respect
and deliver a decent pay rise how many
people have to take part in the march
today for it to be deemed a success well
it's not it's it's not a big National
rally because obviously we do have the
train strikes so we're not bringing
people in from all over the the country
the key thing is we've got 80 events up
and down the country plenty of
opportunities for people to show the
support and later on I'll be handing in
a petition with a quarter of a million
signatures to down the street about the
protecting the right to strike and I
think the government should listen to
people power listen to public opinion
deliver on pay yeah but if you you you
know if you've got a dozen people with a
bull horn and a dog turning up to
Parliament the government are going to
use that as an illustration as to why
you don't have any support yeah well I I
don't think it will be a dozen people
well I think they should be looking at
the fact is that half a million workers
today will be taking strike action uh
that's on top of the hundreds of
thousands have already taken strike
action hundreds of thousands potentially
more to come over the next few weeks and
months they should look at that quarter
of a million signatures they should look
at those events up and down the country
and they should realize they've
misjudged the public mood and I hope
that they do and I hope that they come
to the table do you think there'll be
another national day of action uh well I
I mean I wouldn't rule anything out uh
okay my responsibility is to when
workers take that really difficult
decision to take strike action that we
support them as much as possible that we
amplify their voices and I think you
know the ball is very firmly in the
government's Court let's get round the
table let's resolve these disputes and
let's put money in the pockets of our
hard work and public service worker good
to see you as always thank you very much
for taking the time I know you've got a
busy day thank you